Have you ever tried joining
your seams on the machine?
This is a really fast
way to finish a garment.
You'll be pleased with the results.
First, hang the side of one piece on your
needles with the public or
the right side facing you.
Insert your 2 or 3-prong tool
and pick up the whole edge stitch across
the piece and hang them on the needles.
Next, hang the second piece on the same
needles with the private side facing you.
Be sure that the public sides of the work
are sandwiched together
and they're facing each other.
The trick to a perfect seam is to pick
up both strands of the edge stitch only.
When hanging the second piece,
you might sometimes pick up a leg or
partial strand of an adjacent stitch,
ruining the entire
appearance of your seam.
So go slowly and make sure
the seam is perfect the first time.
When both pieces are on the needles,
pull all of the needles all the way out
and close the latches.
Now don't skip this step.
Make sure those latches are closed.
Starting with the carriage on the left
with the main color yarn, knit 1 row.
From left to right at the
tightest tension possible.
Next, you'll manually knit a very
large stitch on each needle.
Keep these stitches loose so
the seam has some stretch.
You'll want these stitches
to be large but not sloppy.
Practice until you get the tension
At this point, your yarn
will be on the left.
So break the yarn with a—
leave about a 6-inch tail.
Working from the right,
bind off the stitches on the needles
by pulling each stitch through
its neighbor to the left.
Finish by pulling the tail
through the last stitch.
In this image, I used a contrasting
color to show you the seam.
This method adds a bit of bulk,
but the bulk can be reduced by using
a thinner yarn for the seam.
Even with a highly contrasting color,
notice that this seam is very
inconspicuous from the public side.